now we were just talking about the
Chancellor's upcoming statement with the
Shadow Chancellor and we know of course
that the coronavirus lockdown has had a
huge impact across the economy but some
sectors have been harder hit than others
and the futures of some businesses are
looking particularly bleak now this week
I got on the road and traveled to
Birmingham to take a look at the
economic fallout from covert 19 for
Hippodrome Theatre in Birmingham
coronavirus has forced it to shut its
doors for the first time in a hundred
and 25 years the Book of Mormon set that
still on stage an eerie reminder of the
suddenness at the pandemic and as nobody
knows when theaters will be able to fill
their seats again it's an industry in
crisis this week Sam Hamptons Nuffield
theater closed its doors for good
others could follow we're in contact
with our department DCMS and we know
that they're they're working on guidance
for how the sector can reopen the
problem that they have is we don't know
when it will be safe to reopen and to
allow people back into a theatre and so
that does make a really difficult for us
to plan I think if they knew that tell
us that nobody from a health perspective
knows how this pandemic is going to play
out whether they'll be second waves
whether some cities might need to close
again like Lester has so they I don't
think they can in good faith give us a
date right now which does mean it's
impossible for us to plan and in a
sector where 70% of theaters think
they're going to be out of business and
insolvent by Christmas for us we're
really at a crunch time where we need to
know whether we're going to be running a
Christmas season or not and if it's not
we need to know whether there's going to
be any sort of government support
package that can help us through that
period and stop us from insolvency like
many theaters and you know everyday
you're reading of another we have ports
50% of our permanent team at risk of
redundancy and we're working through
that consultation program right at the
moment that must be pretty heartbreaking
it's devastating and we are losing it's
heartbreaking because we're losing such
good talented people people have made a
massive contribution to this sector and
have a huge amount more to give
and because this isn't just us this is
across the country these people it's
going to be very hard for them to get
jobs again in theater we're going to
lose them from the sector we're going to
lose all the skills and training that
they've had and that really is very hard
to cope with I think part of the reason
that you're seeing theaters now go into
massive redundancy programs is because
the job retention scheme in its current
form isn't going to be fit for purpose
for us anymore when we have zero income
coming in and we have no idea when we're
going to be able to reopen our doors the
idea that we can start paying an
employer contribution from August
through to the end of October just
doesn't work for our sector we can't be
paying more money towards stuff because
we can't be bringing them back to work
and we're not trading and how many staff
do you think you'll be forced to lose
I'd say at least 60 new the sector
employs 300 thousand people across the
country and 70 percent of those jobs are
likely to be at risk talking to you
before the interview you talked about
that gallows humor but this must be a
pretty dark time as well it's very dark
time actually it is yes I think before
before before the interview you caught
my comms manager you know head of comms
and I having a laugh in the corner and
it is it's because it's such a dark time
sometimes the only way that you can cope
with it is a sort of gallows humor but
it's actually not funny it's really not
funny I mean we're staring staring right
down the barrel at the moment of having
no theatre left in this country and I
think people might wake up next April
and say oh I really I really fancy going
to a musical and there won't be any
anymore
and there won't be theaters anymore and
if we let this go now it's going to take
decades to rebuild to where it was so
what we're really pleading for at the
moment is date guidance so we have some
idea of when we might be able to reopen
so that we're able to plan and also for
a support package because theatre and
Performing Arts it's not just for
lovey's it's you know it's has a massive
social and civic benefit but it also
it's an economic driver of the nighttime
economy it brings so much more to the
landscape of South towns and cities than
just putting on shows what really struck
me today is just how many jobs are
reliant on the theater this area of
Birmingham is full of shops cafes
restaurants pubs that feel they can't
reopen until the Hippodrome dance it's
like a mini economic ecosystem and right
now it's endangered as the economic
impact of coronavirus begins to be felt
research from the resolution foundation
shows that the low paid and the young
are most likely to be at risk of losing
their jobs if we look at what businesses
say today half of them are saying that
they will lay off some of the workers
that they have furloughed that roughly
equates to maybe a million workers
losing their jobs as the job retention
scheme as the furlough scheme is phased
out that's a lot of people that is a
would take us to the highest
unemployment we've seen at least since
the early 1990s three million people or
10% of the workforce unemployed so this
is a very serious situation and I guess
quite different from previous recessions
where more recently we seen wages going
down rather than people actually losing
their jobs one of the dangers is that
when the financial crisis hit it was a
very deep recession but the level of
unemployment that we feared or worried
about never actually turned up it was
really bad but we didn't see a return to
the 1980s levels of unemployment that
may have bread some complacency because
the conditions are just very different
this time so there are good reasons for
thinking this could be a worse
employment recession than we saw in the
financial crisis and what specifically
is it that you're calling for well I
think later this week the Chancellor
should announce not the VAT cut that
some people have been calling for but
instead vouchers going direct to
households to get them to spend in
retail and in hospitality and the
physical stores not online that is how
we make sure that we have a recovery
that is going at decent strengths and
targets that consumption that's spending
the places that are being hit really
hard so this Wednesday we should see
consumption vouchers being sent to every
house holding an ounce they'll be sent
to every household and we should also
have a plan for jobs we're calling for
17 billion pounds worth spending to make
sure that we subsidize jobs in those
hardest hit sectors but also create new
jobs in the likes of social care and in
retrofitting homes for energy efficiency
there have been some encouraging signs
that our lockdown is eased the economic
recovery has already started but how
optimistic should we be well there's a
lot of evidence
from periods in in recent British
history in the last 3040 years that when
unemployment rises significantly and he
does disproportionately tend to fall on
young young people who either can't get
a job when they leave school a
university or they've only just got a
job and they're kind of last in first
act there's a lot of evidence that
there's a kind of scarring effect that
it affects their employment into the
future and the wages the income that
they're going to earn and that will that
last many years rather than just a few
months so I think unfortunately in the
absence of a very sharp recovery so that
we're back to normal by say November
December which I'm afraid I don't think
is that likely in the absence of that I
think we will have some long term
effects on many young people what is
clear is that the economic consequences
of coronavirus will not hit all people
and all industries equally even if the
bounce back happens it may be too late
for many businesses